I actually have a tremendous amount of
respect for people who are willing to
Traverse miles through desert dozens or
hundreds or thousands of miles because
the dream of America is so incredible
but it's got to be a legal process but
it's not even the dream that's being
sold to them anym it's just the IDE
you're being offer free stuff now you
know I mean this is not the American
dream and I'm suffering so much in this
country and I'm willing to Traverse
through the desert uh for an opportunity
like you said it is now systematic
you're are going to have a better life
as soon as you get here it's all set up
for you you know I met a journalist that
found the dumping point where there
being told to dump all of their idss
they're coming in on flights from other
countries dumping their IDs because
they're being told to she had three bags
filled with their IDs and then they
handed these pamphlets from the UN by
the way which was beyond Bonker she
showed me this pamplet that was coming
from the UN and they're being told to do
this to come into this country because
they know that there are politicians
that are setting up an entire system for
them where their lives will be better so
this is not the same the same mentality
people that are coming at the border
right now we have to let go of this idea
that they're just the suffer offering
people who are willing to do anything
for an opportunity they're just being
offered handouts at the expense of the
Amic an assembly line to bring them in
free healthare and free sex gend changes
I'll use this to segue one of the things
I've heard uh quite a bit many people
back uh in my hometown Chicago have said
I can't afford to pay the rent my
groceries are too expensive we just went
to hi ve grocery store out here it was
great but yo it was expensive I mean uh
we we got I got three things of salami
always love buying salami and cheese dip
a couple things of heavy whipping cream
with our coffee four grocery bags it was
300 300 bucks to be fair we got some
vitamins and some protein powder I know
there's a little bit more expensive but
I was surprised to see this little bit
was so much and I hear people say why
are in Chicago particularly when I went
and visited home they're giving these
they're paying these people rent they're
putting them in hotels they're giving
them our schools they're getting a free
pass from our tax dollars and I can't
afford to pay rent I can't afford to
survive so part of the the immigration
issue that many people are feeling is
the economic hit they're taking we're
paying taxes that are supporting all of
these these these flights where they're
bringing in hundreds or thousands these
buses they're being paid for yes by the
American taxpayer while the American
taxpayer suffers and can't afford to pay
rent yeah and I think actually that's
what makes this a nonpartisan issue this
should I should be a slam dunk issue for
us so I this was your hometown Chicago I
didn't realize that I visited the souths
side of Chicago earlier in this campaign
which is a very traditional campaign
Southshore South Shore yeah and a couple
of different areas too but we went to
South Shore High School is where we
finished the day and oh really is where
you grew up Midway Airport oh two block
away all right well uh good deep dish
pizza and all that you know we we yeah
called sou there's some things to like
well that's the tourist stuffart Pizza
check yeah I mean but that's what I am
when I go I mean we don't we don't get
to go to Chicago every day so we pick
them on the way out but you know it was
interesting where it was a room full you
know maybe like this one little bit
different ethnic composition was 95%
black 150% Democrat as they told me
before you went maybe that's how they
Count Their votes but but anyway it was
interesting right the first part of the
exchange was contentious because some
people came with some questions that
were I think there were some people who
had some real animist to me in that room
one woman she asked me a question walked
straight out because she didn't like my
answer on racial reparations but
actually things changed pretty quickly
when we got to the question of illegal
Mass migration where there literally
converting the local high school into an
encampment for migrants at a cost of
$77,000 per migrant per month when the
people in that Community Americans are
asking the question what about me and
actually later it came up somebody else
asked me on their own I wasn't bringing
up bringing up foreign policy why are we
sending our money to Ukraine almost
challenging me like I was a person who
would presumbly because being a
Republican or whatever believe that this
was a good idea and I explained that no
no no no this is actually a very bad
idea we should not be doing this and we
actually left with a lot of common
ground on both of those issues which is
why I think it's actually very important
not to see the American first movement
through the prism of even the Republican
party I mean the Republican Party means
very little it doesn't mean anything to
be a republican well doesn't predict
what you mean based on on foreign policy
doesn't predict what you think about
Free Speech doesn't predict what you
think about National Security State
overreach so that label means a lot less
but I think that because of what you
just said people I mean it's expensive
right now people are struggling in this
country this is something that should
cross partisan lines racial lines I
think there's an opportunity for us to
deliver a landslide election in 2024 and
a landslide minus some Shenanigans is
still a win which you know I think is
something we have to prepare for and
that's kind of my wholeo in this thing I
saw several polls many of you may have
seen them uh the youth vote swinging
towards Donald Trump that's pretty
shocking but I have to imagine if uh uh
you know from where I grew up in Chicago
I've got my relatives talking about
they're they're talking about building
physical encampments taking a whole area
in the southide and building a camp from
scratch I remember when I was 16 I got
my first paycheck doesn't and everybody
remember that and you're like I was
supposed to get paid you know 8 bucks an
hour I worked x amount of hours and then
you look at your check and you're like
where's my money and then all the older
guys laugh and they were like look at
the tax section it's called theft now
imagine that's right now imagine 16 17
18 year-old kids working their first
first job or whatever get that first
paycheck they see how much money is
taken from them from their hard labor
they they they work their their fingers
to the Bone and then at the same time on
the news your tax dollars $7,000 per
person per month we're talking about
$84,000 a year for free to people who
are not from this country who have not
worked for this country and you
hardworking young men have a third of
your income taken by the government to
give to them and maybe it's because we
have a $34 trillion National Surplus to
spend on this I'm I'm just kidding it's
actually $34 trillion national debt
where we're already in the hole and so
anyway I do think that the silver lining
in this is that the more we kind of talk
about this through classical Republican
versus Democrat you know fire Biden kind
of mentality stuff which is super boring
and not the right way to look at this
election I think the more we're going to
fall into the Trap of getting another
50.1 election we're playing tug-of warar
and msnbc's trotting out the winner six
days after the ballots are
cast that's not the direction we need to
go I think there is a movement that
transcends partisan and racial
boundaries I think it translate it
transcends national boundaries right now
too in many ways what you see in certain
other countries but in this country I a
get 75 80% of this country agreeing on
many of the things we're talking about
right here hypothetical you get elected
day one what do you what do you begin
doing to help alleviate the stress on
the economy and the average person to
help them increase their standard of
living and better the economy yeah look
I think that there's some very basic
things to do one is the easiest thing
you could do to alleviate both the
national debt and the economy at the
same time there's a lot behind this but
I'll just get to the punchline get the
oil and natural gas out from underneath
our ground we know how to do that sell
it
and buy down about $8 trillion of our
national debt that takes us from 34 to
26 next end this you know end a lot of
the Foreign Wars in Ukraine elsewhere
that's another 7 trillion of our
national debt now our national debt
problem 7 trillion was due to Iraq and
Afghanistan and I don't want to be on
the track to do the same thing and then
initiate a mass firing not a chisel but
a chainsaw style firing AA of 70 yeah
75% of federal bureaucrats start that on
day one that is of every four people
there three of them will be gone
definitely by the end of the ter first
term and preferably sooner and problem
is when you got a bunch of those people
showing up to work who should have never
had that job in the first place they
start finding new things to do a lot of
them is writing regulations that
Congress never authorized which is
acting like the wet blanket on the
economy and my first action as it
relates to the regulatory state is any
law that Congress didn't actually pass
or specifically instruct an agency to
write a regulation for it's my view and
the current Supreme Court's view that
it's unconstitutional resend all of them
and state on day one we're stopping
enforcement of those regulations and
view them as null and void that grows
this economy it increases the supply of
housing think about housing we have land
use restrictions we have EPA
restrictions that are limiting new
housing construction increase the supply
brings down the cost grows the economy
energy unlock the supply of oil natural
gas coal nuclear energy increase the
supply bring down the cost grows the
economy stop paying people more money to
stay at home instead of to go to work
increase the supply of labor most small
businesses the hardest thing they find
right now to expand is to hire new
people to fill those roles so even
before I get to reform of the Federal
Reserve which is a favorite topic of
mine that's not a day one item just
literally day one these are the kind of
steps we can put into motion and yes I
think we get back to 4% GDP growth
possibly 5% GDP growth it could be even
magn we might land magnitudes of growth
because what we're going to do is
transform into a hydrogen-based fuel
economy they figured out at Rice
University how to he's not wrong yeah
they take that is interesting need to
hear that but but he's not you know but
I think that uh they figured out how to
make it profitable to make hydrogen
essentially this has been the the entire
time it's like it cost too much money to
make the fuel they figured out you take
plast you take any carbon trash you hit
it with a laser called flash Jewel
heating 7,000 degrees for 0.1
milliseconds and it turns it into you
can get hydrogen and graphine as a
byproduct which you can use as a
building material to build houses build
roads to to enforce your roads by making
them three times stronger is 200 times
stronger than steel by weight this
material pure carbon and for every
kilogram of hydrogen you produce with
this process you get about $4.50 of
graphine and then we can sell the
graphine you can also take the oil that
this would displace technically a
hydrogen economy might displace the oil
you can turn the oil into graphine so we
can keep pumping it and we can keep
selling it now as esoteric as that may
be for many people the core fans of the
show have heard it a million times is
that right I think the the actual simple
message though is innovation in the
energy sector yes Beyond just oil it
could be hydrogen it could be Fusion I
mean there's big breakthrough there
nuclear energy you can pump the hydrogen
through the natural gas lines of the of
the planet so we've already got an
infrastructure the guy's name is James T
at Rice University I'll put you in touch
with if you want to go I would love to
learn more you going to say something no
I was just going to talk about nuclear
energy in terms of one of the main
obstacles to this and this I think to
the extent that this involves actually
what what exactly laser accomplishes but
is it sort of splitting the nucle
electricity oh what do you I think that
it would it would it would it not fall
within the nrc's amb the nuclear
Regulatory Commission no it's not
nuclear this process it's physical
breakdown just physical breakdown got it
so so I'll have to learn more about that
but I'm talking about at least the
production of more kinds of energy in
the United States including nuclear
energy again one of the obstacles is the
nuclear Regulatory Commission and again
the right answer is you can't reform
these agencies I think the right answer
is to get in there and just shut them
down one by one just say
AA no outside you trying to say Fel is
that what he was saying on the could
like throw it out no when
M things off the wall yelling AA you
know I've said this many times if I have
not made Javier Malay look like a
moderate by the end of my first three
months I haven't done my job all right
so I like the guy actually been
following for a long time goes around
with the chainsaw chainsaw first chisel
second yeah I think that's one of the
things that got me excited about you
just as a candidate was just it's
remarkable to me that we have all of
these people that are running and they
make it seem like being America First is
something that's dirty like it's that's
wrong and I just could not get over all
of them paring this point that we could
do both right that drove me crazy I
wanted to scream as I was yeah we can do
both we can take care of the ukrainians
and every other country we can do look
around you that's what I look around you
does it look like we are successfully
doing both have we been successfully
doing both I mean this country has been
in a steep Decline and a large part of
it is because what ends up happening is
what we saw on that stage and what we've
seen uh just throughout this entire
election process is just people are
bought and paid for right and and the
people that they tend to sell out are
always the American people we're told
that we have to feel bad we have to put
ourselves last it's always an American
last perspective y um and so it's just
been exciting to have you get up there
on the stage and everywhere that you've
been going and you've been doing so many
podcasts without question I think
everyone can agree that you have been
the hardest working candidate at this
election cycle I've seen you everywhere
I mean appreciate obscure podcast it's
it's it's really wonderful just the work
ethic is so impressive um and you're
young and I'm a mother of three and so
it was something that was very important
to me and I'm just kind of shwing you
with the compliments here obviously I
appreci thank you that is something
that's very scary for me because when we
talk about even the process of illegal
immigration you think about that as a
parent this is also going to become
issues down the line when we talk about
the violence that is going to be imp
parted in inner cities this is something
that terrifies me something that
terrifies me you have unchecked people
coming into this country we know that
they are coming from countries where the
cartels are running things we have no
idea who is being brought into this
country at this moment as a parent
that's terrifying yes um and I just
think a lot of the candidates are not
willing to talk about these issues in a
way um that is is provides Clarity to
those of us that are worried about the
future for our children I think most I
think most of the candidates are really
reading scripts provided to them by
their super Pacs or the people who fund
them I mean I think that's effectively
what American politics has become for
the worse and I think you got to be
willing to say I mean it's sad the
system works this way but we put our
families put over 25 million close to
$30 million into this campaign there's
going to be more going in it's what it
takes to run presidential elections even
still it's hard to compete against the
Super PAC industrial complex where the
amount of money being spent on
television advertisements by the like of
Nikki haly and Ronda sandz but it's not
really them it's the super Pacs that's
the real cancer on American politics and
the super Pacs culture selects for
candidates that just make them vessels
for advancing what that super pack
industrial complex wants to advance and
so one of the things I think again this
is an opportunity to go beyond
traditional partisan boundaries building
towards a Reagan 1980 style Landslide
you got Ukraine in that category you got
the southern Border in that category I
think we should be favoring ending
ending super packs not by violating any
First Amendment rights but by just
saying that you know what if there's a
$3,300 maximum that you can give to a
campaign that's what it is in the GOP
Primary that's a lot of money but it's
not enough to corrupt a politician who's
running for president that if there's a
Super PAC that's donating to
presidential candidates if you're
donating to that Super PAC you should
also be capped out at $3,300 per PR I
don't think that that's too much to ask
this used to be a left-wing idea
actually I think that right now we're at
a place where the Republican Party
absolutely can and should embrace it I
think it'll be widly popular and again
part of building
towards an 80 plus perc electoral
majority minus sh Shenanigans is still a
decisive Landslide Victory but anyway I
think that's what's going on as you kind
of have candidates when you start to
think that they're actually advancing
their own convictions we're kind of
missing the point they're vessels for
advancing what the donors really want to
wield them to actually stand for there's
this issue in Iowa right now actually
which is super
interesting I was actually at an event
at the state capital earlier today say
like an esoteric issue maybe but it's
not really because it affects every
American is they're building a carbon
dioxide capture pipeline across this
state that we're in right now so they
make a lot of eth in the state they say
capture carbon dioxide build a pipeline
across the state and then bury it in the
ground in North Dakota why no one really
knows why other than the fact that our
federal government's providing subsidies
in the name of fighting climate change
because carbon dioxide is a bad actor it
doesn't make any sense I carbon dioxide
is plant food so this idea of removing
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere being
some sort of worthy goal I could go on
for a full day about why that's based on
a false premise it is but we're using
our own taxpayer money to pay people in
the state there's a business couple
businesses that are now using eminent
domain to seize the land of farmers here
rights to use their land when most Iowa
farmers who I've met do not like that
being built across their backyard so I
could I could go a little bit longer on
this but the point I'm bringing it up is
not a single other Republican candidate
not a single one has expressed
opposition to this carbon capture
pipeline why because the most powerful
people at least in this state as it
relates to the Republican donor
establishment do not permit to oppose
the carbon capture pipeline interesting
and so again it comes back to that Mega
Money In in politics could we go a
little bit deeper here because you you
mentioned the Federal Reserve just a
little bit and this is an institution
created in 1913 that's a quasi private
cartel parading around like it's some
kind of Private Bank when it's
essentially not Thomas Jefferson said
that he believes banking institutions
are more dangerous to our liberties than
standing armies with their corporate
bailouts with the inflation which is
essentially a tax on the poor a theft of
resources from the poorest people in
this country and the FED yes or no I
would like to but that requires
legislation I make promises that I will
keep as your next president and here's
the promise I'll keep with respect to
the FED is a 90% headcount reduction at
the US fed combined with restoring
effectively a single mandate one purpose
Peg the dollar two Commodities stabilize
the dollar as a unit of measurement it
should be just a basic function of
arithmetic and nothing more and again
part of the problem is you got those
23,000 people or so at the US Federal
Reserve now that we don't need to do
that narrow function of pegging the
dollar to Commodities they find things
to do that's where the Central Bank
digital currency comes from that's where
a lot of these the cbdc which is a backd
door way of ensuring a government
surveillance system of being able to
wipe you out for doing something the
government didn't approve of that's how
you get to riging money from on high
like Mana from heaven in the aim of
balancing inflation and unemployment
it's like the equivalent of hitting two
Targets with one arrow and missing it
both so hopefully that answers so thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net